[Music]
fire base storage is now officially
supported by angularfire 2 which means
uploading files from an angular
application is easier than ever before
in this episode I'm going to take you
through the new features in the
angularfire 2 storage module then we'll
use it to build a drop zone file
uploader from scratch in addition to
uploading files to firebase storage it
can also control the entire upload
process by pausing canceling or resuming
an upload
there's a whole bunch of other cool
stuff I want to show you but first make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and grab the
source code from angular firebase com
before we jump into the code I want to
give you a few more details about how
the angularfire 2 storage module works
when we drag and drop a file it's going
to start an angular fire upload task
which will immediately start uploading
the file to your firebase storage bucket
you can then monitor the upload progress
as an observable the snapshot is emitted
several times per second so you can do
things like update your progress bar or
just provide the user with some helpful
feedback when the process is complete it
will give you back the download URL that
you can show in your front-end UI now
let's go ahead and build this thing
we'll start with a brand new angular 5
app and then inside that project install
angularfire 2 and firebase then inside
of your angular environment add your
firebase project config and lastly we'll
go into the app module and initialize
our angular fire app I am bringing in
both the angular fire storage module and
the fire store database for some
advanced stuff I'll show you towards the
end of the video now that we have
angular fire to set up we need a way to
retrieve a file from the user's device
into our angular app we want the user to
drag and drop a file which is a perfect
use case for an angular directive we
want to use this directive on an HTML
element and have it emit custom events
based on certain drag-and-drop activity
we can create custom events an angular
by using a combination of host listener
output and event emitter the first thing
we do is create our custom events which
we do with the output decorator the
first event is called dropped and it is
fired when the user drops their files
onto the drop zone the events going to
emit a file list which contains the
actual files or file that we want to
upload to firebase I'm sitting up a
second event here called hovered just to
emit a boolean based on whether or not
the users hovering over the element so
we can toggle some CSS classes from
there we can use host listener to listen
to the drop event from the browser and
the first thing we want to do is prevent
the default behavior because otherwise
the browser is going to want to open up
a new tab the events going to contain a
file list which we can extract by
calling event data transfer files and
we'll omit that through our dropped
event emitter we'll also set the hovered
event to false that's the most important
part but we also want to listen to the
drag over event and we'll set our custom
hovered event to true when that occurs
then we can omit false on the drag leave
event and we'll also want to prevent
default on these events as well that
gives us a bare minimum drop zone now
let's put it to use in a file upload
component the goal here is to give you a
pretty extensive tour of the new
functionality in the storage module the
first thing we'll do is import
angularfire storage and the angularfire
upload task from there we're going to
declare a few variables the main part of
angularfire storage is the task it's the
object that gives us access to the
observable data and allows us to pause
cancel or zoom and upload one of the
observables that it gives us is that
percentage changes which is really
useful if you're doing something like
showing a progress bar but you can get
even more data than that by observing
the actual snapshot when the upload is
complete you're probably going to want
the download URL which you can also
listen to as an observable the last
thing I'm doing is setting up a boolean
variable so we can toggle some CSS
classes the next step is to inject
angularfire storage into the constructor
then what I really want to focus on is
this start upload method which will kick
off the entire upload process this
method is an event handler and it will
take a file list as an argument which
we'll get from our directive that we
defined earlier so when the drop event
fires it's going to start the upload we
can get the first file from the list by
calling event item 0 a file list is kind
of like an array so you could iterate
over it if you plan on uploading
multiple files at once the next
you might want to do is provide some
client-side validation so in this case
we only want the user to be able to
upload image files we can look at the
mime type on the file that was selected
and if it's not an image we'll just go
ahead and console error and return from
this function and because we want full
stack security we're going to mirror
this logic in our back-end fire based
storage rules to do that we look at the
incoming request and make sure that the
content type matches image now that
we've secured our upload we need to tell
firebase where to actually save it
storage doesn't generate a unique ID
like the fire store database does so
it's generally a good idea to give your
file path some sort of unique identifier
so it doesn't get overwritten by a file
of the same name the easiest method is
just to use a JavaScript date with get
time and append it to the file name
that's going to make file name
collisions extremely unlikely you can
also save your own custom metadata on
the image itself there's probably a ton
of different use cases but for now I'm
just going to pretend that I have
multiple apps and I want to know which
app actually uploaded this image let's
say it was uploaded from my angular
fire-powered progressive web app at this
point we have everything we need to
define the actual upload task to do that
we call storage upload and we pass it
the file path as well as the file itself
and an object of our custom metadata and
the metadata is completely optional by
the way when we call upload it's going
to immediately start the upload process
there's no need to call subscribe on it
like you would with an observable it
works by giving us observables that we
can listen to to monitor the actual
upload progress we get the observables
by calling percentage changes and
snapshot changes and the last thing
we'll do is set a download URL which is
an observable that emits once the upload
process is complete now one final thing
I'm going to do is determine if an
upload is active so we can toggle
between the paused and resumed States
every snapshot that gets emitted has a
state which might be running or paused
and we can also look at the bytes
transferred and compare them to the
total bytes in the file the data
contained in the snapshot can be very
useful for customizing the behavior of
your front-end UI now let's jump over to
the component CS
I'm not really going to talk about the
CSS but I do want to give you one
helpful tip the snapshot emits data in
chunks so you can smooth out the
transition on your progress bar by just
adding a simple CSS animation in this
case a transition animation on the width
was hugely helpful at smoothing out the
progress bar now let's jump over to the
HTML and put everything together first
we'll set up a div and add our custom
drop zone directive to it that will give
us access to our Hubbard event to toggle
the CSS class and also to our drop event
to know when the files were dropped in
this div that emits a file list which
we'll pass on to our start upload method
to immediately start the upload process
in addition to drag and drop we also
want to give it just a plain file upload
button this is especially important on
mobile devices because it will bring up
the user's camera which will allow them
to either take a picture or select an
existing picture on their device all we
need is an HTML input with the type of
file and then we'll bind it to the
change event and fire off the same start
upload method that's all it takes to
build a drop zone but we also want to
show a progress bar to do that we're
going to use the percentage observable
that we set in the component type script
we can unwrap it with the async pipe and
then set it as a template variable
called % idiom it's a number ranging
from 0 to 100 and we can use it as the
value in our progress bar that's really
handy but we can also take this a step
further and unwrap the snapshot in the
HTML as well the snapshot contains
information about the bytes transferred
and the total bytes in the file
that's not very user friendly by itself
but what I did is create a file size
pipe that will round it to the nearest
format such as megabytes kilobytes etc
the pipe was really easy to create
because I borrowed all the source code
from the Wrangell io angular training
book on custom pipes and I recommend you
do the same the next thing we can do is
unwrap the download URL we can give the
user a URL to download the file directly
but since we're dealing with images here
we can also set that URL as the source
of an HTML image now the only thing left
to do is set up a few buttons here so
the user can toggle between pause cancel
and resume on the upload task doing that
is incredibly simple
all we have to do is set up a button and
bind the task paws method to the clicky
ban then we only want the user to be
able to fire this if the upload is
actually active at the time so we can
use that is active helper that we
already defined and pass it the snapshot
we also have a cancel method on the task
which we can set up in the exact same
way then if the download is paused we
want to give the user a way to resume it
so to do that we call task resume and
this button should be disabled unless
the snapshot state equals paused and
just like that you now have your own
angular fire drop zone but we're not
quite done yet because I did promise you
one more advanced thing with firestorm
there's a good chance you want to access
your file later on so we can save
information about that file in the
firestore database we can do this with
just a few lines of code first we'll
bring in firestore and a tap operator
from rxjs then we'll inject angular fire
store in the constructor because we
already have an observable of the
snapshot changes for the upload we can
pipe in the tap operator to make a call
to our database once the upload is
completed what we want to do here is
make sure that we only fire this on the
last snapshot which is going to happen
when the bytes transferred equal the
total bytes of the file then we can
simply make a reference to our fire
store collections which I'll call it
photos and then we'll add some data
about this file the only important piece
of data to save here is the file path
because you can retrieve that from your
database and then make a call to storage
using the git download URL method to
retrieve the actual file now let's jump
over to the firebase console and make
sure everything works first we'll look
in our storage bucket just to make sure
our images are being uploaded along with
their associated metadata and you can
see the metadata down here at the bottom
then if we jump over to the firestore
database console we should see this
photos collection along with the file
path to that actual storage location in
other words you have successfully
connected your persistent app data with
your stored files I'm going to wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and you can
look forward to a whole bunch more
videos in the near future involving
angular fire storage thanks for watching
and I'll see you soon